don't kill my son she begs this mother
is desperate her youngest child is on
death row in Thailand migrants from
Myanmar soul in a way Pio had been found
guilty of murdering two British
backpackers in 2014 three court appeals
have failed so now the mothers have come
to Bangkok to ask for a pardon from the
king
she'll be back at those away chefs will
be back and mad that on my heart like
this about it the badly beaten bodies of
David Miller and Hannah wither egde were
found on the holiday island of koh tao
in september 2014
Hannah had been raped police say DNA
evidence that the scene matched the men
but they and their families claimed they
were framed and tortured until they made
false confessions we shoot them and they
be good paparazzi do you think I wish I
mess with your mother and she shall be
there
thank you my daughter what y'all gonna
do but you know that no one can please
deny allegations of torture
adding neither man has made any legal
complaints Thailand's highest court
upheld the guilty verdicts so now these
mothers are pleading for a stay of
execution life in prison instead by you
[Music]
you told me the king is now the only
person who can overturn these death
sentences and although executions are
rare in Thailand they do still happen so
while the families can do is wait
they say this is now their last chance
their final hope after five years the
decision to execute their sons could
come at any time
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Bangkok